so Assassin's Creed it's our anniversary
again what a wonderful time of year to
celebrate all the great years we've had
together eight years eight can you
believe it
eight years we've done so many things
Paris the Caribbean
I was great constantinople of course
that wasn't so great but we've had some
wonderful times some great adventures
mirrors
but it's just not doing it for me
anymore so I I think it's time I think
it's time we had the talk
my love affair with this series hit me
hard back in 2007 while those early
years were exciting I like many gamers
think this relationship is waned in
recent years so it's probably about time
we had a heart-to-heart
you know just we're real honest with
each other say our piece put it all out
there so today on the point I'm going to
talk about my relationship with
Assassin's Creed and how it's turned
from one of the most exciting games of
recent memory to a beautiful forgettable
sandbox
we associate the AC series with large
open worlds but in spite of its scale
the first Assassin's Creed game was
incredibly linear you completed missions
in the order they were presented and
usually in a particular way it wasn't
Deus Ex so there wasn't much agency when
it came to solving missions but it
didn't matter the world around the story
made it feel like a believable place
even if it was one that you didn't
really do much else in Assassin's Creed
2 and Brotherhood evolved the series by
layering more gameplay elements
alongside the main linear missions there
were aspects of role-playing and more
player agency within missions you could
swim disarm people buy shops
hide in any crowd fire groups to help
you so overall you interacted with the
wider world a lot more it felt more real
and this is why I think those two games
are universally beloved they struck a
balance between creating a world in
which you had agency but wasn't simply a
bunch of mechanisms created especially
for you the player the player had an ark
you developed your skills learn the
environments and built a relationship
with the game world however but if I'm
revelations came around the layered
gameplay was starting to get out of hand
instead of the game giving you choices
it was now a shopping list of things you
had to do to complete the game so while
the second game made you feel connected
more with the world revelations were
starting to feel like a sandbox it gave
you so much to do right off the bat that
you never had an ark you were a powerful
video game character who is here to
solve problems by the time Assassin's
Creed 3 came out well that game was not
only a massive laundry list of chores
but they weren't that fun to do and
while at one stage the worlds in these
games felt like real places you were
taking a part in now they were just sand
boxes that felt like they've been made
especially for the player they felt like
fake video game
and for gamers who enjoy - in
Brotherhood that loss was incredibly
disappointed so it's no surprise that
the series ended up at Black Flag a game
which is about as far down the sandbox
rabbit hole as you can go it's got a big
ol ocean full of ways to upgrade your
ship and repeatable missions for you to
complete and that's where opinion on the
series differs the most some people love
black flag because they love open-world
sandbox where as players like me players
who enjoyed the believable worlds of a
seas of old well it just never struck a
chord assassin's creed had lost
something something nuanced and
difficult to describe you know like it's
sold when you walked around the streets
of Damascus in the sastras creed one you
felt like you were walking through time
you felt like life was happening all
around you and while these new
assassin's creed worlds look incredible
they feel totally bereft of life Unity's
paris was breathtaking well when it
worked but its gameplay was painfully
mediocre just another endless list of
boring missions to complete in a world
which knows I'm the player and for me
the same can be said of syndicate and in
a world where Metal Gear Solid 5 exists
that's just not enough for me anymore
Assassin's Creed syndicate is a sandbox
game and while the sandbox is beautiful
it's totally proactive believability or
gameplay innovation this is a game in
which you play two characters that
represent two different gameplay
strategies and use them to take over
London by completing missions across a
number of its poorest Evie is stealth
girl while Jacob is punch boy though the
stealth is so basic and the punching so
button mocchi that they really shouldn't
have gone to the effort the stealth is
painfully rudimentary you will get
caught often and you'll solve this by
button mashing on an enemy until they're
dead once they are dead likely nobody
noticed your fight and you'll go back to
being stealthy until you're caught again
you may remember a few weeks ago I made
a video about the emergent gameplay in
Metal Gear Solid 5 well if that was a
celebration of the wonders of emerging
gameplay Assassin's Creed is a sobering
reminder of the games that just don't
bother somebody who lived in London for
four years I was incredibly impressed by
the digital capital that Ubisoft have
created
it's a gorgeous surprisingly accurate
reminder of all the places I used to
cycle around drunk at 3 a.m. but once
again like some sort of Charles Dickens
Truman Show its inhabitants seem to only
exist to serve as wind
dressing for the player somehow the
twins are instantly recognizable by the
enemy gangs despite having just moved to
London a city of over 3 million people
at that time you can fly through crowds
of pedestrians diehard trilogy style
without ever alerting the police all the
gang members look the same you're gonna
murder the same ball dude and lady
thousands of times and while we're on
that point this is a game where you
murder countless numbers of street thugs
to install your own Street dogs not
invading soldiers or oppressive
government goons just gang members
products of the underclass this is a
game about killing poor people and
freeing child laborers only to make them
work for you yes this is a game that is
so soulless that the only way to
interact with the dozens of begging
children that litter London's streets is
to hire them to work for your gang you
can't even press X to just give them
some coin and for me somebody who
remembers the carefully crafted wondrous
worlds of those early games all this
stuff just piled on top of one another
and leaves me despondent I mean even
climbing the linchpin of the series has
been reduced to a button some of my most
memorable moments from the early games
involve figuring out how to climb the
tallest buildings climbing used to be a
craft finding a route of the Cathedral
in Accra with your palms sweating on the
controller now the game is so apathetic
to climbing that you just press l1 to
Batman your way to the top of buildings
it's a game that just seems terrified to
piss off the player it lacks any
confidence to try something challenging
or new but here's the thing if you like
games like say Mad Max you're probably
going to like syndicate it's not a
terrible game
it's just largely uninteresting to
somebody like me
it's that same sandbox checkbox game
you've played a bunch of times
and this is why you get such wildly
different review scores this is why some
gamers will like syndicate and others
will be completely bored by it for me
Metal Gear Solid is the perfect inverse
of Assassin's Creed syndicate mgs 5 is
set in a [__] desert with cookie
cutter bases and mission types but the
gameplay is so enjoyable that it doesn't
matter that it all looks the same
while assassin's creed with all its
gorgeous environments is the most
beautiful looking mediocre game I have
played in here
I guess I just want this game to be
something that it's not anymore and
that's probably an unfair expectation on
my part so I'm just gonna stop fighting
it I'm gonna stop being frustrated with
Assassin's Creed I'm sorry you deserve
somebody who can love you for who you
are and that's just not me anymore there
are plenty more fish in the sea it's
like I guess it's over
I've been [__] The Witcher this whole
time